Living your WHY means that
when we make decisions
we are conscientious about
having our WHY front-and-center.
That we consider whether we are helping
bring our WHY to life or advance our WHY
or not.
Look we can always make the decision
not to
but I would rather do that consciously
and know why we're choosing to do it.
It's like living a healthy lifestyle
and choosing to eat chocolate cake.
It's totally fine
but you do it with eyes wide open
knowing that
you have to work out a little more
over the weekend
or you just don't do it that often.
So it's the same thing.
WHY provides that focus and direction
so we can live with purpose
on purpose.